[Music]
you've mentioned sex a number of times
good sex and this is important to many
if not all couples
and i'd love to
pose a
situation and hear how you might
approach it and that is
couple who
love each other dearly they actually do
not seem to be shutting down at least
obviously
they've been together a long time and
maybe the
passion the fire has simply
died down somewhat they're more
i don't want to say roommates because
that has a pejorative
sound to it but they're good parents
they love each other they maybe still go
on dates and so on but
for whatever reason that sexual spark
is not as strong as it used to be
how would you approach
that situation that couple what's always
interesting to me about sexuality and
sexual conversations is that our
world arguably
i mean sex is everywhere now compared to
even say
20 30 years ago
theoretically we're more open and we're
more accepting about sex we're not so
restrained and all that so what's
fascinating to me is it seems to me
that
people
couples have an incredibly hard time
having a conversation about their sex
lives and that's still true and it was
true 30 years ago and it's still true
now
and i think it's because
in sex people are literally naked
they are vulnerable
and they don't know how
to even begin that conversation so what
we do is we create safety in the
relationship we have them look at the
relationship and we walk into that
conversation one of the big
conversations about that one is there's
a lot of evidence now i think it's
really good research
about the difference between male and
female sexuality
and there's a lot of evidence that
women respond differently to
physiological to sexual cues a woman can
be physiologically aroused for example
by a sexual cue if you look at her in an
mri study i think this was by a man
called gilath
basal canadian researcher also talks
about this there's quite a few people
i think chisholm talks about it so the
evidence is a woman can be
physiologically turned on and if you ask
her if she's turned on she'll tell you
no whereas with a man physiological
arousal and experience just goes
together like that they have an erection
they say i'm aroused with the woman
there's something else that seems to
happen what seems to happen
is that the woman's physiologically
aroused and then her prefrontal cortex
cues in
and her prefrontal cortex
the theory now is from these studies
that her prefrontal cortex basically
checks out the safety of the
relationship
which makes sense because women are i
mean let's face it if you look at the
sex act
women are vulnerable
they're naked they're going to open
their body they're going to be
penetrated by a stronger
animal
this is a basic thing so it's almost
like women check out the relationship
and the connection and the safety before
they then feel
they actually let themselves feel
aroused
and so women take longer often to be
aroused somebody said to me what's the
best foreplay i can do with my wife i
said well have you heard her talking
here
i think what she's telling you is the
best roleplay you can do with your wife
is to talk to her and share with her and
turn up well basically i didn't say turn
up emotionally but you know that's where
i was going you know like
show her who you are you know stand out
on the dance floor open your arms you
know it's like and so women have a
slower pace often women have responsive
desire they don't start off from lust
they start off from being open to their
partner or being curious they don't
start from the same place as men and
people haven't known how to talk about
that
and so men and women miss each other and
also men
men talk about how the classic
story is that men start talking about
how they want sex
but time and time again when we're
dealing with a couple sexual
relationship if you really go in and you
really stay there
it's not just about orgasm because let's
get real if it's just about orgasm men
can give themselves an orgasm very
efficiently and so can women there's
amazing vibrators out there okay so
that's not an issue so but it's not just
about orgasm because if you listen to
the man who says who's always badgering
his wife for sex
what it comes down to is
on an emotional level and he has a hard
time getting there
he wants to feel wanted
he wants to feel desired
and in that men and women are the same
and when that somehow a couple give each
other the message
i don't particularly desire you
one way of dealing with it if you have
other good things in the relationship is
to just shut that part of your
relationship down and numb it out
but you can bring it alive
but you have to be able to be aree you
have to be able to take some emotional
risks you have to turn and say you love
this kind of sex well i want to tell you
that for 20 years i've hated it i hate
it
one lady said
you think it's the sexiest thing in the
world to come up behind me and bite my
neck i hate it when you do that
and he says
what are you talking about and she just
didn't feel safe enough to turn and say
i hate that and here's why i hate it
people hang back they shut down but you
know passion is about
feeling
safe enough to be completely absorbed in
the experience and let it take you over
passion is about full engagement
and we talk about it it's all about
novelty it's not all about novelty
novelty can turn passion on but the
research is clear from people like
lauman at the university of chicago the
people who have the best sex have it
most often and who feel most enthralled
find it most thrilling are people in
what you would call safe long-term
relationships
because then you can let go you can
passion is about erotic play you can let
go and play and lots of couples have
sort of put that part of their
relationship off to the side they
haven't known how to tune into each
other they haven't maybe accepted their
own emotional needs they haven't known
how to talk about it so we simply create
safety and we open it up for them
and they start to
share and talk
and find it again
they have to have acceptance
somebody has to be able to say
i was bought up a catholic
there's some part of me that can never
quite accept my own sexuality
and some part of me just needs you to be
dominant to demand it of me and then i
can get turned on well she needs to be
able to tell that to her partner because
he's always comes onto her considerate
and low-key he doesn't want to offend
her in any way well it doesn't work
right so people have to be able to
examine the way they dance together and
share and then they can
find each other and it's the same with
sexual problems you're in hold me tight
one of my favorite stories i've got it
in the book of the man who has erectile
dysfunction
and the trouble is not that he has
erectile dysfunction the trouble is he
freaks out every time he has erectile
dysfunction and shuts down and
withdrawals from his wife and then she
gets upset and feels rejected and
abandoned so the whole relationship
starts to go to hell when they can talk
about it connect with it
and i suggest that you know
sometimes i think we call his penis
george i can't remember now that i say
sometimes george goes for a little nap
and it's no big deal if they can stay
connected with each other and she can
help wake george up you know she knows
how to do that they laugh and they play
and there's no problem after a while
because they deal with it differently
because they have this safe connection
but the trouble was the sexual problem
was interfering with their safe
connection and everyone was playing it
safe and being nice to each other and
keeping everything calm
the thing is
what we've learned about attachment
science can help us shape our emotional
relationships
and our sexual relationships
it gives us a map for how to do that
and
it really
challenges the old cliche
that love and
passionate love has a best before date
it really challenges that
you